oh mein gott
egal ich sag mal gar nichts bei diesem
spiel wurde mit 100 mich echt nichts
mehr
[Musik]
ja komm mit pikachu so nein nein ach das
ist doch geil wenn die mich die ganze
zeit haben hier los pikachu du schaffst
es nie kommt hier restart durchs wilde
gras ab zu professor eich und das
picacho kommt jetzt mit und ich glaub
jetzt schaffen wir das eigentlich los
runter da so alles gut
ich lass mich mal bitte vorbei fast
komplett wieder ein top blogger ich
glaube wir haben
hey das ist weg geil cool
okay was haben wir hier um mein gott
einfach wie hießen die normalen die uhr
und so keine ahnung
peter g aachen onyx kacke pikachu
donnerstalk vielleicht
nach wie wärs pikachu von strong von
unix take my breath drop dead end in
front
ja interessant wenn wir tot sind kommen
das level mich zu ändern dann haus hier
ist mein gott oh mein gott keinen
kommentar ab also es geht eigentlich
viel mehr darum diese level zu genießen
zuschauer nicht schön das ist und halt
spaß an der ganzen sache zu haben dass
ihr euch unterhalten führt zum beispiel
wenn gerade langeweile abrupt einfach
dazu wie er fiel bei happy meals und
dann ist euer tag gerettet wie gesagt es
geht um den unterhaltungswert und nicht
um den skill losschneiden nicht hinter
dem fahrrad wir schaffen das los ich
finds auch interessant ob diese levels
jetzt bei 49 09
der muss auch richtig geld haben beide
das hier alles genau so programmiert hat
dass dieses dass diese poker darum
fliegen und so viel ich folge was man
hierfür für möglichkeiten hat ich glaube
ich sollte nicht bei den level editor
ansehen wie kannst du mal bitte vor
vielleicht muss das extra so gemacht
sein dass pikachu vorgeht nein nein nein
auch aber ich kann auch fahren
ok pikachu zerstört sehr schön
ein coil pikachu nein nein nein nein
okay hey was soll das denn ich war von
pokémon center und auf einmal bin ich
tot
also eigentlich bewegt das pokémon
center das komplette gegenteil war kein
ding die usa auch interessant wie
schnell die vorgeht
jetzt habe ich dort voll bock auf dem
pokémon let's play ohne mist schreibt
mir meinen die kommentare ob ihre
pokémon let's play wollt also darauf
hätte ich jetzt mal evans
er kann auch sein dass ich dann
irgendwie okay schreibt einfach nicht in
die kommentare
ich denke das ist viele von euch wollen
viele vielleicht auch nicht die wahllos
donnerstalk oder ihn was
nein ich nicht mit die black alter
picacho bist du sollst das ding töten
nein oder ja verdammt wieso können
endlich auf wasser fahren wo ist denn
unser pikachu jetzt in acht uhr musste
das also so gehen wir hier weiter so
zack zack
weiter weiter hier so pikachu zerstörst
du das mal bitte wo wir können noch
fahren ist doch alles gut team rocket
blast auf at the speed of light um mein
gott mir hat genau so pikachu
donnerstalk vielleicht ja donnerstalk
pikachu ich weiß nicht ob du das kennst
aber gbk piaggio da können wir nicht
einfach so durch fand ja ok cool ich
habe es geschafft hast du hängst in der
pedale
mein gott wie jobcenter pen forderte das
heißt die fans einfach mal hier runter
ja perfekt hier ist der erste worden
dick da guckt euch mal den kopf und das
motto ich hatte angst vor mir oder auch
nicht nein ich möchte gern die die
engine rauskriegen wie die jetzt hier
rumfahren was das soll hallo mein helm
safety first pitch please
nein nein nein ach verdammten folco
galli wollte ballack ich weiß nicht so
wie sesam ist mein kind dieser also
nicht ist mein kind sondern ist mein
kind auf den wieder sagen mein kind wäre
das eher blöd so und zack mit den ersten
ball und jetzt noch über die versam da
los war
ach so und wenn ich ein pokémon als plan
würde dann auf jeden fall eines der
älteren weil diese neuen definierte
komplettpaket mit den ganzen verdammten
kag pokémon die sind so und jetzt haben
wir auch mal haben wir es auch mal hier
bald der ok just found its board cheryls
geil geil ich will auch hugh hefner
abends users hallo fahren wir dann mal
okay dann mach ich halt alleine youtube
alter dabei - richtig geil ich hab mir
früher immer mein pokal für new
aufbewahrt
auch nur noch mal
[Musik]
ich glaub muss ich das echt immer wieder
von vorne machen egal kommen mal was
noch mal von vorne hier hop und zack und
wenn wir es nicht schaffen können sie
auch einfach abbrechen wenn ich jetzt
nicht bis zu der stelle komme in der ich
wohin war dann spiele ich da auch nicht
mehr weiter das ist doch das regt mich
dann auf das dann blöd na ja oh mein
gott
pikachu geht mir bitte vor
danke so wir sind noch komplett heile
auf jeden fall
von daher dürfte uns eigentlich erst mal
nichts passieren und mein gott wer im
pkw überholt der platte mal bitte eben
hier drauf auf mich oder über mich
drüber keine ahnung wie du willst ja
klar fliegt noch weiter weg wenn du bist
echt zu blöd
natürlich jetzt schafft pikachu das
natürlich okay kaum einmal versuchen was
noch ich will dieses level durch kriege
ich das total geil finden aber ich wette
ihr hasst mich jetzt total dafür dass
ich das nicht kann ich heiß auf relativ
einfach weiter hier einfach durch und
hob professor eich weg und pikachu eben
überholen
letzter versuch letzter versuch leute
jetzt ganz vorsichtig relax runter
kicken langsam runter fahren wie lachse
drüber ab zu professor ich das pikante
schon mal vor laufen
okay wir werden jetzt erst mal ein
anderes level probieren so was ja auch
super mario auch klein und pokémon
training war was dafür keine sachen
dabei sind das hätte ich ja gar nicht
gedacht zahlt sich das erste level
gesehen habe
das ärgert mich gerade super mario 64
hier mit den ganzen türen und so werde
jetzt einfach mal nicht so viel um mein
gott solche 3d animationen hier auch
machen
man sieht ja schon dass das ein wenig
3ds ja was haben eigentlich hier unten
ach ja und es läuft ein anderer weg kein
guter weg nein
indem wir den weg oben her achso los
jetzt hier hapert drüber halo ist ob
durch das bild jetzt sind wir hier in
dieser welt okay hier hier werden wir
doch irgendwie drunter her kommen ohne
dass der uns frist oder
ich habe mir schon mal ein bisschen vor
ja den 91 hier so was ist jetzt hier
es geht weiter so cool danke so ach so
einander nicht die falsche taste ich
muss jetzt hier rückwärts drücken
genau so macht man das und erst wieder
am boden
ach dieses komplettes spiel das ist doch
na ja jetzt einmal schaffen 100 prozent
die schnelle verspreche ich euch hier
bei meinem namen nenne ich das tue ich
lieber doch nicht
aber das haben wir bisher ganz gut
geschafft so jetzt gibt er uns hier hoch
sodass das müssen wir irgendwie schaffen
hier
hallo so soll jetzt hoch hier aber nicht
zu schnell der stern dahin ist mir egal
ich möchte mich nicht in die luft
fliegen
und was mit der kugel machen weiß nicht
hat auch nicht ach die soll der reinfall
nach so ja okay jetzt weiß ich natürlich
worum es geht
das heißt ich muss erstmal da hochkommen
die kugel runter lotsen und dann
wiederum fahren also so wie ich dann
erfuhr hat sich der denn jetzt bitte
verletzt naja so ich werde jetzt einfach
noch vier minuten aufnehmen und wir sind
schon wieder
aber ich kann noch fahren kann ich nicht
mein gott okay ganz schön von vorne hier
hab ich will dass dieses mario level
noch lösen bevor ich jetzt gleich ein
aufnahmestopp mache
nur was ich mir wünschen würde wenn da
oben irgendwie eine uhr wer bzw 1
prozent anzeigen wieviel prozent man wie
viel prozent vom level man schon hin
gekriegt hat august ist kann es
millionen nachkommen
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein hier
was wir für die geschwindigkeit drauf
haben hier drauf jetzt hab hier darauf
also bisher sind wir wirklich relativ
schnell bei der sache kommt kommt kommt
kommt kom kom kom kom auf einem rad
kommen lassen wir das alter das darf
doch nicht wahr sein
ich drücke das ding hoch was man machen
muss und was passiert ich sterbe mein
kopf bleibt da drin stecken
hallo das ist doch wird hier egal
familie weiter hier
naja das seien dann so ich glaube ich
drehe das nächste auch diese komplette
blut rate runter weil das einfach nur
irritiert finde ich ein bisschen eklig
so ist hier hoch jetzt hinterher so
perfekt perfekt getarnt jetzt hier drauf
was mich doch drauf so und jetzt hier so
perfekt langsam langsam langsam wieder
zurück fahren letzte versuche jetzt hier
so jetzt hier über perfektes nicht
gestorben dabei jetzt hier um es die
kugel
auch er das darf doch nicht wahr sein
ich werde mir das nächste mal auf jeden
fall ein anderes level suchen was ich
machen werde
ich verstehe nicht warum ich hier bei
schon verpacke ich meine ist sind das
jetzt hier die schwierigen ich glaube es
sind eher neue level level die halt
vorgestellt wurden
vielleicht muss ich mal einfach
leichtere sachen nehmen oder das sind
schon leichte sachen und ich will
einfach nur schlecht naja schreibt mir
wie immer im ersten paar habe ich schon
gesagt schreibt mir jetzt in die
kommentare
einerseits wollte er dass ich das
weitermache und andererseits soll ich
mal irgendwann etwas was mit pokémon zu
tun hat let's play also das wird mich
auf jeden fall interessieren was er denn
da in die kommentare schreiben werdet
also zum beispiel erstens macht es
weiter zweiter
auch von mir aus gerne pokémon na ja ich
würde sagen wir sehen uns denn ihr wollt
im nächsten part happy meals und dann
will ich sagen sehen wir uns im nächsten
video